I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hey. Oh, hi.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的“办公室爱侣”播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事，带你更深入地了解《办公室》的世界。我们是 6.0 版本的办公室女士。嘿。哦，嗨。
How are you, lady? I'm good. Me too. I need an update from us. Oh, yeah? I want to check in on our New Year's resolution. to get off the hamster wheel. How's it going? Well, pretty good. I hamstered a little bit on Saturday.
你好呀，女士？我很好。我也是。我们得更新一下彼此的近况。哦，是吗？我想跟进一下我们的新年决心：摆脱仓鼠转轮般的生活。进展如何？嗯，挺好的。周六的时候我稍微像仓鼠一样转了转圈。
I know you did. And then I put it away. I put work away. And then I have started purging my closet. This is what I did with this extra time. Yes. And I'm so happy about it. And also, like, I went through and there's some stuff in my closet that I'm like, it doesn't really fit me anymore, but I still like the stuff. And I put together like a little pile. And Isabel got to go through it all. And she was so. so excited. It was like shopping in mom's closet. Oh, I'm sure. Yeah. Because you guys are the same size. Almost. But her feet are bigger than yours, right? Her feet are, she's tinier than I am, but like overall, but her feet are bigger, which makes her crazy because she's like, oh, you have so many great shoes. Well, I have added on to getting off the hamster wheel. I have added on doing one thing at a time, which I found has been really good for me. I think I used to pride myself on being, an expert multitasker, and I want to become an expert single-tasker.
我知道你转了。然后我就把它收起来了。我把工作收起来了。接着我开始清理我的衣橱。这就是我用这些多余时间做的事。是的。我为此感到非常高兴。而且，呃，我翻找了一下，发现衣橱里有些东西我觉得“它其实已经不合身了，但我还是很喜欢它”。于是我把它们堆成了一个小堆。伊莎贝尔把这些衣服全都挑了一遍。她太兴奋了。就像在妈妈的衣橱里购物一样。哦，我敢肯定。是的。因为你们俩穿同一个尺码。差不多。但她的脚比你的大，对吧？她的脚是……她比我更娇小，整体上是这样，但她的脚比我大，这让她抓狂，因为她会说：“天哪，你有这么多棒极了的鞋子。”好吧，为了摆脱仓鼠转轮的生活，我又加了一项内容。我加上了“一次只做一件事”，我发现这对我真的很有帮助。我想我以前曾为自己是一个精通多任务处理的人而感到自豪，而现在我想成为一个精通单任务处理的人。
I like that. Single-tasking. You know what multitasking's overrated? I think so. And I think, again, especially as a person who works from home, I don't want to put in a load of laundry while also answering an email. So I've stopped doing that. I have work hours and I have home hours, and I'm actually finding that I'm happier,
我喜欢这个。单任务处理。你知道多任务处理被高估了吗？我也这么觉得。而且我觉得，特别是作为一个在家工作的人，我不想在回复一封电子邮件的同时还去洗一缸衣服。所以我不再那样做了。我有工作时间，也有家庭时间，我实际上发现，当我把它们分开，而不是试图让它们同时进行时，我会更快乐、
more present and more efficient in those spaces when I divide them up rather than try to like make them work together. I like this. I've started doing this thing. Tell me if you think it's passive aggressive. I'm excited. I'm sitting up. Okay. So whenever someone's on a device in my house, like we start a conversation and then maybe they check an email or look at a text, I stop talking. Oh. Just mid-sentence. I love this. I stop talking.
在这些领域里也会更专注、更高效。我喜欢这样。我开始做这样一件事。告诉我你觉得这算不算被动攻击。我好兴奋。我坐直了。好吧。每当我家里有人在玩电子设备时——比如我们开始对话，然后他们可能去查收一封邮件或者看一眼短信——我就不说话了。哦。就说到一半停下来。我太喜欢这个了。我不说话。
And then inevitably, they realize and they look up and I go, hey there, let me know when you're ready. Oh, lady. I'm living for this. Here's a thing. I'm trying to have a conversation. Yeah. I don't want to have a conversation with the top of your head while you're looking at a
然后不可避免地，他们意识到了，抬起头来，我说：“嘿，准备好了就告诉我。”哦，女士。我太支持这个了。事情是这样的。我是在跟你对话。是的。我不想对着你的后脑勺说话，而你却在盯着一个
device. And I have a house full of teenagers. We're learning our boundaries with devices, right? Mm-hmm. Social cues and whatnot. Yes. And I think this is a good life skill to take out with you that when someone's talking to you, you focus on them.
电子设备。而且我家里有一群青少年。我们在学习如何为电子设备设定界限，对吧？嗯哼。社交暗示之类的。是的。而且我认为这是一个很好的生活技能，带出去也用得上：当别人跟你说话时，你的注意力要在对方身上。
And then if you have an email or something you need to check, then you go do it. I like this. I think this is smart. I think this is good parenting. Maybe it's passive aggressive if you want to give it that label, but it's also proactive life lessening. Okay. How about that spin on it? There's our self-help book.
然后，如果你有电子邮件或其他需要查看的东西，你再去弄。我喜欢这样。我觉得这很聪明。我觉得这是很好的育儿方式。如果你想给它贴上被动攻击的标签，那也许是的，但它也是一种积极主动的减压生活方式。好吧。对这种说法有什么看法？我们的自助书诞生了。
Proactive life lessening by Jenna and Angela. All right, everyone, welcome to this week's Office Lady's 6.0. Today, we are going to be breaking down the third episode of Season 1's The Paper, titled The Buddy and the Dude. Yeah. But before we dive into that, we are going to kick things off with a chit-chat, sent in from Steve T from Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. Hi, ladies. This is Steve from Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. I'm curious what your preferred thermostat setting is, both in the summer and the summer. winter. My fiance and I both like to keep the house pretty cold, so any warmer than 68 degrees and we feel
由珍娜和安吉拉合著的《积极主动的减压生活方式》。好了，各位，欢迎收看本周的《办公室女士》6.0。今天，我们将剖析第一季第三集《报社》，剧集名叫《哥们儿和老兄》。是的。但在我们深入探讨之前，我们将以一段由宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的史蒂夫·T发来的闲聊来拉开序幕。嗨，女士们。我是来自宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的史蒂夫。我很想知道你们偏好的恒温器设置是多少，无论是在夏天还是冬天。我和我未婚妻都喜欢把家里弄得比较冷，所以任何高于68华氏度的温度都会让我们觉得
like we're roasting. That is not the question I was expecting. But okay, what were you expecting? I don't know. I wasn't expecting a thermostat question, but I sort of love it. It's very timely for me, Steve. I don't know how you knew this. Well, I loved this question because this has been a theme in my life, the thermostat war. Yeah. I mean, especially on the set of the office. We had Steve Correll, who ran hot. And so on the days he was there, the air was like cranked down. And then we were all freezing and we would have little heaters under our desk. But I guess I should also talk about what it's like at home. Well, he's asking our preferred setting. Yeah. What is yours, lady? Well, my preferred setting is 70 degrees air conditioning at night. Really all I care about right now, Steve, is what is the temperature at night when I'm trying to sleep through my hot flashes?
像在烤火。这可不是我意料之中的问题。不过好吧，你刚才期待什么？我不知道。我没料到一个关于恒温器的问题，但我有点喜欢它。对我来说这很应景，史蒂夫。我不知道你是怎么知道这一点的。嗯，我很喜欢这个问题，因为这一直是我生活中的一个主题：恒温器大战。是的。我是说，尤其是在《办公室》的片场。我们有史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，他是个怕热的人。所以在他在的那几天里，空调都被开到了最大。然后我们所有人都冻得要死，我们会在办公桌底下放小暖气片。不过我想我也该聊聊家里是什么情况。嗯，他问的是我们偏好的设置。是的。你的呢，女士？嗯，我偏好的设置是夜间70华氏度的空调。史蒂夫，现在我真正关心的其实是，当我试图忍过潮热安然入睡时，夜里的温度到底是几度？
Sure. But right now in L.A., it's getting very cold at night. And so the problem is when I'm going to sleep, I need the air conditioner on. But then the house might get all the way down to like 66 degrees overnight if the heat isn't on. Yeah. I'm really in a pickle. I'm fighting with it. I'll get up in the middle of the night. I'm worried the kids are cold, so then I turn the heat on and then I'm sweating. This is a long story to say my preferred setting is 70 degrees. At night. At any time. 70 seems to be my sweet spot, but I live in a very old house and different rooms run hot and other rooms run cold. And it's very hard to keep everybody happy. So we have a few space heaters. My son sleeps with his wind. open a little bit because his room runs hot. It's a whole thing. I'm going to throw you a curveball.
当然。但现在在洛杉矶，夜晚变得非常冷。所以问题是，当我入睡时，我需要开着空调。但如果暖气没开，夜里房子可能会一路降温到大约66华氏度。是的。我真是陷入了两难。我一直在跟它作斗争。我会在半夜醒来。我担心孩子们会冷，于是我打开暖气，然后我就开始流汗。说了这么长的一堆废话，其实就是想说我偏好的设置是70度。在夜里。在任何时候。70度似乎是我的最佳舒适点，但我住在一栋非常老的房子里，不同的房间温度偏热，而其他房间则偏冷。要让每个人都满意真的很难。所以我们有几个空间取暖器。我儿子睡觉时窗户
What is it? Your face is so funny. Why? You're like, what is it? I turn off the heat at night. I know. Me too. That's what I'm saying. No, no, but like I let it get down. Like, it doesn't kick on ever. And I sleep with the window open. And it gets cold. Like, you wake up and the house is cold. But I like to sleep in a cold room. I'm with you, Steve. I'm like, I tell the kids, guys, pile of on the blankets. Okay. And I sleep with the window open no matter where I am. So like we go to see Josh's family in Colorado in the winter. I open that window. You know, that's really healthy I was reading about it. Oh yeah? We're supposed to be getting more fresh air into our homes than we're getting. Oh. Like you're supposed to remember in Ye Olden times when there was no like, you know, HVAC systems.
会开一条缝，因为他的房间比较热。这真是个麻烦事。我要给你抛出一个曲线球。
Yeah. You had your windows open a lot. Yeah. And that's really good to get that fresh air. I'm that person. I have windows open all over the house. Smart. I like it around 64 degrees at night. Sixty-four. Yes. Yes. That's what the thermostat said this morning when I woke up. It said it was 64 degrees in the house. And I just, oh, man, I just layer these heavy blankets and I'm so snug. But it is hard for me to get out of bed in the morning because I'm so snug. There you go. 70 and 64. Yeah. Those are our numbers. Thanks, Steve. Love your question. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? Because when we come back. We've really got a lot of fun stuff to share about this episode. Yes, we reached out to Greg
是什么？你的表情太搞笑了。为什么？你那表情好像在说，是什么？我晚上会关掉暖气。我知道。我也是。这就是我要说的。不，不，但我是让温度自然降下来。就是，它从来不会自动启动。而且我睡觉时开着窗户。而且会变得很冷。就是，你醒来时家里是冷的。但我喜欢在寒冷的房间里睡觉。我和你一样，史蒂夫。我跟孩子们说，伙计们，多叠几层毯子。好吧。不管我在哪里，我睡觉都开着窗户。所以比如冬天我们去科罗拉多看乔许的家人时。我都会把那扇窗户打开。你知道的，那真的很健康，我之前读到过。哦，是吗？我们本该让更多新鲜空气进入我们的家中，而实际并没有达到那个量。哦。就像你应该记得在古时候，那时候没有什么，你知道的，暖通空调系统。
Daniels. Yes, and I traded some texts with writer Patrick Kang and also Chelsea Fry. And we have a little something something from Creed Bratton. I'm really excited about that one. I know, me too. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down, what might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things.
是的。你们以前经常开着窗户。是的。呼吸那些新鲜空气真的很好。我就是那种人。我家里到处都开着窗户。真聪明。我喜欢夜里大约64华氏度。六十四度。对。对。今天早上我醒来时，恒温器显示的就是这个。它显示家里是64度。然后我只要——哦，天哪，我只要把这些厚毯子层层叠叠盖在身上，我就觉得特别暖和舒服。但早上要让我起床太难了，因为我太舒服了。就是这样。70度和64度。是的。这就是我们的数字。谢谢你，史蒂夫。喜欢你的问题。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？因为当我们回来时。我们真的有很多有趣的事情要和大家分享关于这一集的幕后故事。是的，我们联系了格雷格·
Mm-hmm. Because those really just add up. Mm-hmm. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things. Mm-hmm. BetterHelp therapists can help.
丹尼尔斯。是的，我和编剧帕特里克·康以及切尔西·弗莱交换了一些短信。我们还有来自克雷格·布拉顿的一小点神秘惊喜。我对此真的超级兴奋。我知道，我也是。本节目由BetterHelp赞助播出。你知道的，仅仅因为迎来了新年，并不意味着你必须变成一个全新的自己。但也许你想成为一个负担更轻、思路更清晰的自己。不是脱胎换骨，但也许就像是你想磨砺一下自己。你想精进一下。是的。我喜欢这个词：精进。嗯，心理治疗可以帮助你更轻易地识别是什么在让你感到沉重，是什么在拖你的后腿。你可以更好地理解自己的人际关系、你的动力、你的情绪。我正试图放下对一些小事的焦虑。
With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, h-elp.com slash office ladies. Okay, we are back. Let's discuss today's the paper episode. It is season one,
嗯哼。因为那些小事真的会积少成多。嗯哼。而且它们最后都会没事的。嗯，你可能需要有人帮忙辨别什么是小事，什么是大事。嗯哼。BetterHelp的治疗师可以帮到你。
episode three, titled The Buddy and the Dude. It is written by Patrick Kang and Michael Levin. Guess what show Patrick worked on before? Like back in the day, you're not going to guess. I'm going to tell you how I met your mother. I might have guessed. I didn't give you time to guess. I was thinking like, oh, it's got to be something we're connected to. That's where my brain was going. Okay.
BetterHelp拥有超过3万名治疗师，是全球最大的在线心理治疗平台，已为全球超过500万人提供过服务。BetterHelp让你能轻松在线匹配到合格的治疗师。注册并在 betterhelp.com/officeladies 上获取 10% 的折扣。网址是 betterh-elp.com/officeladies。好的，我们回来了。让我们来讨论今天《报社》这一集。这是第一季
Isn't that crazy? Yeah, a small world. I know. And this episode was directed by Yana Gorskaya. Are you ready for a summary? Yes. All right, here it is. In this episode, Ned scrambles to teach his staff about the importance of fact-checking sources.
第三集，剧名叫《哥们儿和老兄》。由帕特里克·康和迈克尔·莱文编剧。你猜帕特里克以前在哪档节目工作过？就以前，你绝对猜不到。我要告诉你了：《老爸老妈浪漫史》。我本来也许能猜到。我都没给你时间猜。我当时还在想，哦，这肯定跟我们有什么联系。我的脑回路当时是朝那个方向想的。好吧。
Mayor pitches an undercover investigation into a shady mattress pricing scam. Meanwhile, Esmeralda continues her attempts to sabotage Ned, including revealing the fact that mayor might have a plan to leave the paper for a job in hospitality. All right, my single fast fact is a fun guest star crossover. Mary Hollis and Bowden plays Cindy, the mattress store employee. She's got a really great big guest star on this episode. You all might know her from her many roles on shows like HBO's The Righteous Gemstones or AMC's Kevin Ken F himself or maybe ABC's The Real O'Neils, which is where Angela, the two of you met.
是不是很疯狂？对，世界真小。我知道。这一集由亚娜·戈尔斯卡亚执导。你们准备好听剧情梗概了吗？准备好了。好的，剧情是这样的：这一集中，内德手忙脚乱地教导员工核实消息来源的重要性。
Yep. You had a two-episode guest arc on that show, and I remember you telling me how much fun you had and how nice Mary was to you on the set. She's great, and I just enjoy her. Every time I'm around her, we've reconnected a few times throughout the years. She's just wonderful. And I reached out to her for this episode. You did.
梅尔提议对一起涉嫌欺诈的床垫定价骗局进行卧底调查。与此同时，埃斯梅拉达继续企图破坏内德的计划，包括透露梅尔可能打算离开报社去酒店业工作的一个计划。好的，我唯一的快速冷知识是一个有趣的客串明星联动。玛丽·霍利斯·博登饰演辛迪，即床垫店的员工。她在这集里是一个非常重磅的客串明星。大家可能通过她在许多剧集中的角色认识她，比如HBO的《副校长》或AMC的《奈德·克鲁夫本人》，或者可能是ABC的《真实ONEALS》，安吉拉，你们俩就是在那部剧里认识的。
You asked her about her time on the paper. She sent us some great behind-the-scenes details. We're going to sprinkle those in as we break down this episode. But the first question you asked her, of course, was, how did you get your job on the paper? And it turns out, she first auditioned for a series' regular role on the show when they were casting the pilot. I know. How about that? She said she spent, quote, most of February 24 auditioning under a cloak of secrecy.
是的。你在那部剧里客串了两集，我记得你告诉我你玩得有多开心，而且玛丽在片场对你有多好。她超棒的，我真的很喜欢她。每次我和她在一起都很开心，这些年来我们还重新联系过好几次。她简直太棒了。为了这一集，我联系了她。你确实联系了。
A month of auditioning for a series regular role in the show. That she knew nothing about. She said it, quote, could not be named. How crazy is that? All she knew was that Greg had created a show. She was pretty sure it was the paper. But she said it was hard to manage all the emotions around an opportunity that exciting. She also said the material was clearly decoy pages, which made it obvious that they were really just searching for the right ensemble chemistry.
你问了她关于在《报社》工作的经历。她给我们发了一些很棒的幕后细节。在我们剖析这一集的过程中，我们会把这些内容穿插进来。不过你问她的第一个问题当然是：“你是怎么得到《报社》的工作的？”结果证明，她最初在剧组挑选试播集演员时，是为剧中一个常规角色去试镜的。我知道。怎么样？她说她花了，“引用原话”，在2月24号的大部分时间里，都在极其保密的情况下进行试镜。
I thought that was so smart of her to like realize that. If I got decoy pages, I was trying to think about it. Would I really understand, like, are they trying to get a sense of my timing, my comedy? But I think it's about personalities. Like, how these people are going to mesh together? Yeah. And I remember Chelsea telling us something similar when we interviewed her. Yeah.
花了一个月的时间为剧中的一个常规角色试镜。而且对该剧一无所知。她说这“根本不能说名字”。有多疯狂？她唯一知道的是格雷格创作了一部剧。她很确信那就是《报社》。但她说，面对这样一个令人兴奋的机会，要掌控所有的情绪真的很艰难。她还说，剧本材料显然是诱饵剧本，这使得很明显他们实际上只是在寻找合适的演员组合化学反应。
Well, ultimately, they went in a different direction for the series' regular role, but Mary said in a truly generous twist, they invited her to join this episode as Cindy, no additional audition required. Oh, that's so nice. She also said shout out to good casting directors who keep track and remember all the people who might sit into the world of the show. Well, I just love that. And we have some more fun tidbits from Mary as we break down this episode, but how about we get started? Let's do it. The episode starts with Ned. He's in his office, and he's working off a dry erase board coming up with story ideas. Did you zoom in on the dry erase board?
我觉得她能意识到这一点真是太聪明了。如果我拿到诱饵剧本，我肯定会琢磨。我真的能明白吗，他们是在试图了解我的节奏感、我的喜剧感吗？但我觉得这关乎个性。就像这些人将如何融洽相处一样？是的。我记得切尔西我们在采访她时也说过类似的话。是的。
No, did you? Yes, I did. Oh. Okay, so here are the story ideas they're working on. First of all, on the dry erase board, there's all these squares, kind of like a layout, you know? And in the squares, here's what they say. Feel Good Story. Photo.
好吧，最终他们为这个常规角色选择了不同的方向，但玛丽说，在一次真正慷慨的转折中，他们邀请她作为“辛迪”加入这一集，无需额外试镜。哦，太好了。她还对优秀的选角导演表示了感谢，他们会追踪并记住所有可能适合该剧世界观的人。好吧，我太喜欢这个了。在我们剖析这一集的过程中，我们还有更多来自玛丽的有趣花絮，不过我们怎么开始呢？开始吧。这一集从内德开始。他在自己的办公室里，正对着一块干擦白板构思故事创意。你放大看那块干擦白板了吗？
Water Department Update. Downtown Construction. Senior Center. shoplift story, mud hens game. Mud hens? Exactly, lady. What is a mud hen? Well?
没有，你看了吗？对，我看过了。哦。好吧，以下是他们正在构思的故事创意。首先，在干擦白板上，有许许多多的方格，有点像某种排版布局，你知道吗？而在这些方格里，写着这些内容：暖心故事。照片。
Mud hen? Like a hen that, like blaze an egg? Mud hen? M-U-D-H-E-N. Mud Hens game. Well, you know I had to Google it. What is it? Turns out the Toledo Mudhins are a minor league baseball team.
水务局动态。市中心建设。老年中心。抓小偷的故事，泥母鸡队比赛。泥母鸡？没错，女士。什么是泥母鸡？好吧？
Oh. Yeah. Their AAA affiliate is the Detroit Tigers, but they are located in Toledo, Ohio. and they play their home games at fifth third field. Oh. But again, what is a mud hen, you might say? Are you going to tell me? I am.
泥母鸡？就像一只会下蛋的母鸡？泥母鸡？M-U-D-H-E-N。泥母鸡队比赛。好吧，你知道我不得不去谷歌一下。是什么？原来托莱多泥母鸡队是一支小联盟棒球队。
According to the Internet, here is how they got their mascot name. A mud hen is a marsh bird with short wings and long legs, and it inhabits swamps or marshes. I guess the Toledo mudhins earned their name in 1896. That's going back. That's going back. I guess that's the year the team played at Bayview Park, and it was surrounded by marshlands and these birds hung out there. Oh. There you go. And the article goes on to say the abundance of mudhins near the park brought about the nickname and the rest, as they say, is history. Wow.
哦。是的。他们的3A级附属球队是底特律老虎队，但他们位于俄亥俄州的托莱多。而且他们的主场比赛在第五第三球场举行。哦。不过话说回来，你可能会问，什么是泥母鸡？你要告诉我吗？我要说了。
Toledo mudhins. So someone's going to report on that game. It's making me wonder how the St. Louis Cardinals got their name. Were they playing and a bunch of Cardinals flew by? How'd that happen? I don't know. I don't know. I mean, I really want to now check out a Toledo Mudhins game. I'm invested. You are? You're going to follow their season now? I might have to go find them online. Does the board say anything about the status of all of these articles by any chance? No. No status updates. Okay. Well, Mayor is going to walk in and they've got this like really cute shorthand now. Yeah. They're going over a story about the inspection budget. You know who they should follow up with. And they both say, Angie. Yeah. They've got someone on the inside. It's so cute. They've got a
根据互联网的说法，他们的吉祥物名字是这样来的：泥母鸡是一种短翅膀、长腿的沼泽鸟，栖息在沼泽或泥地里。我猜托莱多泥母鸡队是在1896年得到这个名字的。那可真够久远的。那确实很久远。我猜那是球队在湾景公园打比赛的一年，那里周围都是沼泽地，这些鸟儿就在那里闲逛。哦。就是这样。文章接着说，公园附近大量的泥母鸡带来了这个绰号，正如他们所说，剩下的就是历史了。哇。
nice groove. Adam enters. And instead of calling Ned Ned, Ned, he calls him Ed. Ned corrects him, and he's like, no, no, I'm calling you Ed. It's short for Editor-in-Chief. I wanted to save some time. I'm sorry. Hold on. Yeah. Flag on the play. Who does this remind you of? I mean, Kevin. Why waste time? Say lot word when few word do trick. I know. I thought the same thing. I mean, is there a world where one day Kevin shows up as Adam's cousin? Like, are they related, these two people? I think a big yes. And they just don't say very many words. They leave words out of their sentences, and that's their bit.
托莱多泥母鸡队。所以有人要报道那场比赛了。这让我想知道圣路易斯红雀队是怎么得名的。他们当时在比赛，然后一群红雀飞过？那是怎么发生的？我不知道。我不知道。我是说，我现在真的很想去看看托莱多泥母鸡队的比赛。我入坑了。你入坑了？你现在要关注他们的赛季了吗？我可能得去网上找找看了。白板上碰巧有提到所有这些文章的状态吗？没有。没有状态更新。好吧。这时梅尔走了进来，他们现在有了一种非常可爱的速记暗号。是的。他们在讨论一篇关于检查预算的故事。你知道他们该跟谁跟进。他们俩同时说：“安吉。”是的。他们有内应。太可爱了。他们配合得
And they have weird number combinations. Maybe so. Yeah. Well, Adam has come into Ned's office. to turn in his article about a man who stuffed a dice and down his pants at Target as a joke. His source is the man himself. Yeah. Ned asks Adam to consider that maybe his source is lying to him. Uh-huh. Adam's like, I don't think so, I don't know. And then Ned is like, you know what?
相当默契。亚当进来了。他没有叫内德“内德、内德”，而是叫他“埃德”。内德纠正了他，说：“不，不，我叫你埃德。这是‘总编辑’的缩写。我想节省点时间。抱歉。”等一下。是的。暂停，有违例。这让你想起谁了？我是说，凯文。为什么要浪费时间？当少数字就能搞定的时候，干嘛要说很多字。我知道。我也这么想。我是说，有没有这样一种可能：有一天凯文作为亚当的表亲出现？比如说，这俩人有亲戚关系吗？我觉得很大可能。而且他们都不怎么说很多话。他们会从句子中省去一些词，这就是他们的梗。
I'm going to make this the lead story of the also news. And this is where we find out that articles that aren't sourced well are maybe, maybe they're just not good. They end up in the also news because Ned doesn't want to hurt people's feelings. Yeah. And Adam, as it turns out, is the star reporter of the also news. Yeah, the also news is just printed on the copy machine and distributed it internally. And we all know who else would be in the also news.
而且他们有奇怪的数字组合。也许吧。嗯，亚当来到内德的办公室，
Kevin. Well, now Ned is going to call the whole team into the conference room. He wants to coach everyone on separating fact from fiction. This is obviously for Adam, mostly, but maybe for everyone. I think for everyone. He proposes that they play the game, two truths and a lie, so that they can help learn discernment. Right. He puts Travis and Adalola head to head.
是来交他的文章的，讲的是一个男人为了恶作剧把骰子塞进裤裆里的事。他的消息来源就是那个男人本人。是的。内德让亚当考虑一下，也许他的消息来源是在对他说谎。嗯哼。亚当说：“我觉得没有吧，我不知道。”然后内德就说：“你知道吗？我要把这个作为‘副刊新闻’的头条。”这就是我们发现的地方：那些消息来源不佳的文章，可能，也许它们就是不怎么样。它们最后会进入“副刊新闻”，因为内德不想伤害别人的感情。是的。而亚当，事实证明，正是“副刊新闻”的头条记者。是的，“副刊新闻”只是在复印机上打印出来，然后在内部传阅。我们都知道还有谁会出现在“副刊新闻”里。
They're going to go first. They have to say two truths and a lie, and you have to figure out which one is the lie. I want to point out at one minute, 38 seconds, that Barry is opening up a flask that he's now going to drink. Yes, I saw that. I love that he smokes and tricks whenever there's a conference room. Here are the two truths and a lie that Adelola says. Ready? Yes.
凯文。好吧，现在内德要把整个团队都叫进会议室。他想指导大家如何区分事实与虚构。这显然主要是针对亚当的，但也可能是针对所有人的。我觉得是针对所有人的。他提议大家玩个游戏，叫做“两真一假”，这样可以帮助大家学会辨别真伪。对。他让特拉维斯和阿达洛拉进行对决。
I buy a new toothbrush every week. I can't feel pain on the bottoms of my feet. And I once misdialed a phone number and accidentally called Martin Lawrence. Yes. Travis says, I think your story of accidentally calling Martin Lawrence is the lie because you would never sit on an anecdote that strong. And I've never heard that before. Yeah, he calls BS on that. Mm-hmm.
他们先来。他们必须说出两件真事和一件假事，而你必须猜出哪件是假的。我想指出的是，在1分38秒的时候，巴里正在打开一个他接下来要喝的扁酒壶。是的，我看到了。我喜欢每当有会议室场景时，他就会抽烟和变魔术。以下是阿达洛拉说出的两真一假。准备好了吗？是的。
Well, guess what, you guys? Adelola whips out her phone and calls someone, and you hear this. Okay, who doesn't have any good stories? Oh, my goodness, you reach Martin Lawrence. When you hear that beat, you know what to do? What? What? Yeah.
我每周买一支新牙刷。我的脚底没有痛觉。我曾经拨错电话号码，不小心打给了马丁·劳伦斯。是的。特拉维斯说：“我觉得你那个不小心打给马丁·劳伦斯的故事是假的，因为你绝不会把这么猛的趣闻压着不说。而且我以前从未听说过这个。”是的，他当场指出这是胡扯。嗯哼。
Yeah. Martin Lawrence. So I thought, oh, my God, how do they get Martin Lawrence for this? This is amazing. What a get, right? Well, that's what you said. And I said, I don't think it's Martin Lawrence. And I said, well, I'm going to call Greg.
好吧，你们猜怎么着，伙计们？阿达洛拉掏出手机拨通了一个人的电话，你听到了这个声音。好吧，谁没有几个好故事呢？哦，天哪，你联系上马丁·劳伦斯了。当你听到这个节拍时，你知道该怎么做。什么？什么？是的。
Greg said it's actually an impression by comedian Jay Farrow. Oh, I love Jay from S&L. Yes, he's so great. He was on S&L from 2010 to 2016. He does a ton of amazing impressions. I actually went down the rabbit hole and watched him on an interview nine minutes of impressions. Yes, I saw that because the guy's just like throwing. names at him and he just can do it. It's amazing. See, that fascinates me because I can get honing
是的。马丁·劳伦斯。所以我当时想，天哪，他们是怎么请到马丁·劳伦斯来客串这个的？这太惊艳了。真是个了不起的邀约，对吧？好吧，你是这么说的。而我说，我觉得这不是马丁·劳伦斯。然后我说，好吧，我要打电话给格雷格。
an impression and then doing it, but like switching between accents or switching between impressions one right after another. Like, how do you do that? It's amazing. And he does, he did this whole bit where it was like Martin Lawrence and Will Smith going back and forth, but he does both of them. And their cadence is so different. Yeah. He does so many amazing impressions. Anyway, shout out to Jay Farrow, you totally had me fold. And then we go on to find out that Adelola did one time call him by accident, and he thought she was his niece. And they had this really nice heart to heart about her spending habits. But now whenever she calls him, it just goes to voicemail. Have you ever played two truths and a lie, Ange? Uh, no, I haven't. I haven't either.
格雷格说这其实是喜剧演员杰·法罗的模仿。哦，我太喜欢杰在《周六夜现场》的表现了。是的，他太棒了。他从2010年到2016年一直在《周六夜现场》。他模仿过超级多厉害的人。我实际上顺着网线去看了他的一次采访，有整整九分钟的模仿秀。是的，我看到了，因为那家伙简直就是别人抛出什么名字，他就能立刻模仿出来。太神奇了。看，这让我很着迷，因为我可以理解把一种模仿练纯熟然后再表演出来，但像是在不同的口音之间切换，或者一个接一个地模仿不同的人。这到底是怎么做到的？太神奇了。而且他做过整个一段表演，就像是马丁·劳伦斯和威尔·史密斯来回对话，但他一个人分饰两角。他们的说话节奏完全不同。是的。他模仿得太棒了。不管怎样，向杰·法罗致敬，你彻底把我给唬住了。然后我们接着发现，阿达洛拉确实曾不小心打错过他的电话，而他以为她是他的侄女。他们还就她的消费习惯进行了一次非常温暖的谈心。但现在每当她打电话过去，都直接进语音信箱了。安吉，你玩过两真一假吗？呃，没有，我没玩过。我也没玩过。
I don't think I'd be good at it. No. You wouldn't be good at giving the things or you wouldn't be good at guessing. I think I wouldn't be good at giving the things because I think I probably would have a tell. Oh, yeah. Yeah. My tennis gals, they said they can always tell when I'm going to go down the line, like go down in the alley. They said I get this kind of like expression. So maybe you would have tells. I think so. I mean, I think I'm better at lying over the phone than in person if history has taught me anything. Sure, because then we can't see your face. Yeah. It's. Exactly. Well, we find out that Adelola is pretty good at two truths and one lie. And, you know, we were talking about this and I thought, I want to play this, but I want to play it with Creed Bratton. Yes. He's the master of saying all kinds of crazy shit that we think isn't true, but then it is true and then we don't know what's not true. And I called him up and he said, I'll do it. Let's go, gals. He sent us in, you guys, three audio clips where he does two truths and a lie. We don't know what they are. We haven't listened to them.
我觉得我不会擅长这个。不。你是不擅长出题，还是不擅长猜？我觉得我不擅长出题，因为我觉得我可能会有破绽。哦，是的。是的。我的网球姐妹们说，她们总是能看出我什么时候准备打直线球，也就是打到边线去。她们说我会有那种特定的表情。所以也许你会有破绽。我想是的。我是说，如果历史能教给我们什么的话，我觉得我在电话里撒谎比当面撒谎要擅长得多。当然，因为那样我们就看不到你的脸了。对。就是这样。好吧，我们发现阿达洛拉在“两真一假”上相当擅长。而且，你知道的，我们之前在聊这个的时候我想，我也想玩，但我想要跟克雷格·布拉顿一起玩。是的。他是那种会说各种疯狂屁话的大师，我们觉得那不是真的，但结果它偏偏是真的，然后我们又分不清到底什么不是真的。我给他打了电话，他说：“我玩。来吧，女士们。”他给我们发来了，你们知道吗，三段音频剪辑，他在里面玩了“两真一假”。我们不知道它们是什么。我们没有听过。
And then he sent us in an additional one where he reveals which one is the lie. But before we play them, I have to tell you, Jenna, right before he sent us these clips that we have not listened to, he called me. Okay. And he said, hey, Pumpkin. He was like, I'm going to need some room here. And I was like, huh? And he goes, to kind of get into it. You know, I want you guys to believe it.
然后他还额外给我们发了一段他揭晓哪一个是假的音频。但在我们播放它们之前，我必须告诉你，珍娜，就在他给我们发送这些我们还没听过的剪辑之前，他给我打了电话。好吧。他说：“嘿，南瓜。”他当时说：“我在这儿得有点发挥空间。”然后我说：“啊？”他说：“就是为了融入其中。你知道的，我想让你们相信。”
So, like, is this a one sentence, a two sentence? or do I have some room? Well, lady, this is what you need. You need room when you're telling a lie. I learned this from when I was a struggling actor, and I would have to fib my way out of, like, work to go to auditions. And you have to, you have to spin a yarn. Yeah, I think that's where the phrase comes from, right?
所以，这是要说一句话、两句话？还是说我有一定的发挥空间？好吧，女士，这就是你所需要的。当你撒谎时，你需要发挥空间。这是我从自己作为一个苦苦挣扎的演员时学到的，当时我得编造谎言来请假去参加试音。你必须得编故事。是的，这个短语就是这么来的吧？
You really have to tell a tale. So I said, Cree, babe, you do you. Like, give it to us the way you want to do it. So we have not heard these. But, okay, everyone listening, we are all now going to play Two Truths and a Lie with Creed Bratton. Listen with us, and let's see if we can all guess. Back in the early 80s, I was involved in this drug deal, and I ended up owning a 1958 Gibson Carina explorer, one of the rarest guitars on the planet. I think there was only 20 of them made.
你真的得讲个故事。所以我说：“克雷格，宝贝，做你自己吧。按你想要的方式给我们讲。”所以我们还没听过这些。不过，好吧，所有收听节目的听众，我们现在都要和克雷格·布拉顿一起玩“两真一假”了。和我们一起听，看看我们能不能都猜出来。早在80年代初，我卷入了一场毒品交易，最后我拥有一把1958年的吉布森卡里娜探索者吉他，那是星球上最稀有的吉他之一。我想总共只造了大约20把。
This was like one of the earlier, even though that only. 20, one of the earlier serial numbers on that. And later on, I had to sell it for some reason. And I mean, I mean, God, it's probably worth $800,000 to a million dollars today, something like that. It was a loss. Okay. Okay. I mean, I'm already just, I'm so, I'm in. I'm waiting. I know. Here we go. Number two. In 1965, I was doing a movie in Israel, and I came on the set and was leaning against this wall. And unbeknownst to me, there were live squibbs, explosives in the wall.
这把吉他是较早的一把，虽然只有20把，但它是那里面序列号更靠前的一把。后来由于某些原因，我不得不把它卖掉了。我是说，我是说，天哪，今天它对收藏家来说可能值80万到100万美元，诸如此类的。这可真是个巨大的损失。好吧。好吧。我是说，我已经……我完全投入了。我正等着呢。我知道。我们听第二条。1965年，我在以色列拍一部电影，我来到片场，靠着一堵墙站着。而我不知道的是，墙里面有带电的爆破装置，也就是炸药。
And this gentleman walks over to me and he says, hey, kid, you're going to blow your arm off or kill yourself. And he's going to lead me away from the thing. And that man was Frank Sinatra. He probably saved me losing my arm or my life. Thank you, Frank. Ooh. Now that's a tricky one because he told us in his All About Creed episode that he did that movie and that Frank Sinatra was in it. Yeah.
然后这个绅士朝我走过来，他对我说：“嘿，孩子，你会把胳膊炸断或者把命丢在这儿的。”然后他把我从那个东西旁边拉开了。那个人就是弗兰克·辛纳屈。他可能救了我，让我免于失去手臂或生命。谢谢你，弗兰克。噢。这可真是个棘手的谜题，因为他在他的“关于克雷格”那一集中告诉过我们，他确实拍过那部电影，而且弗兰克·辛纳屈也在里面。是的。
So is he using a little bit of the truth? That's very good strategy. I know. Oh my gosh. This one's titled Plain Crash. It was either 67 or 1968. and I'm flying in a little piper cub over the Florida panhandle and with the grassroots. And we're getting ready to land for this show.
所以他是利用了一部分真实经历吗？这真是个非常聪明的策略。我知道。哦，天哪。这一条的标题是“坠机”。那是67年还是1968年，我和草根乐队一起正坐着一架小型派珀小鹰飞机飞越佛罗里达狭长地带。我们正准备降落为演出做准备。
And we hear the guy say it over the radio said, all right, the landing area there, blah, blah, so I got a red light and a green light. And I look down and I see a blue, blue and a yellow light. So I started explaining to the guy. I said, hey, you know, those aren't the color. her little right colored lights. And he turns around and goes, look, you play guitar and I'll fly the airplane. So then, and I felt really bad, I had a bad feeling about this, you know, this
然后我们听到对讲机里那个人说：“好吧，那里的降落区是，巴拉巴拉，所以我看到了一盏红灯和一盏绿灯。”而我往下看，我看到的是一盏蓝色、蓝色和一盏黄色灯光。所以我开始向那家伙解释。我说：“嘿，你知道的，那些可不是正确颜色的灯光。”然后他转过身来说：“听着，你弹你的吉他，我来开飞机。”所以接着，而且我当时感觉真不好，我对这次降落有一种不祥的预感，
landing. So we land on the runway and there's debris all over and it blows out the tire on the right and we end up in a canal with one wing down into the water. Everyone's, you know, I'm calm. I'm cool because I'm creed. I'm chill. The next thing I know, over the hill, I see, see this light from a, you know, truck or something, back landing this military guys with machine guns and dogs, these big, big Alsatians. And they've got the guns on us, get out of the planes. We start to crawl off the wing into the water and looked out in the water,
所以我们在跑道上降落了，到处都是碎片，右边的轮胎爆了，最后我们冲进了一条运河里，一个机翼插进了水里。每个人都，你知道的，我很镇定。我很冷静，因为我是克雷格。我很酷。接下来的事，我看到山坡那边亮起了一束光，来自卡车什么的，带着机关枪和狗的大兵们撤了回来，是那些巨大的阿尔萨斯狼狗。他们把枪对准了我们，“从飞机上滚出来”。我们开始爬出机翼掉进水里，往水里一看，
and there's alligators. There's alligators in the water. And so now we're going to get attacked by the alligators or eaten by the dogs or shot by the soldiers. So they grabbed me and put handcuffs. on me and took me off to the brig as I was on a restricted military base. Yeah, that's the story. Holy crap. So we have to pick two of these are the truth and one is the lie.
水里全都是短吻鳄。水里有短吻鳄。所以现在我们要么被短吻鳄攻击，要么被狗吃掉，要么被士兵枪杀。于是他们抓住我，给我戴上手铐，把我带去了禁闭室，因为我当时在一个戒备森严的军事基地里。是的，这就是那个故事。见鬼。所以我们必须在这三个里面挑选两个是真的，一个是假的。
Yeah. Okay, so we have guitar from drug deal. Right. Frank Sinatra saving his life. Or landing plane crash. A plane crash landing in a Air Force Base? Yeah, a restricted Air Force Base. Air area. Yeah. I think the lie is plane crash. I, but I think it's only half of a lie.
是的。好吧，所以我们有：毒品交易得来的吉他。对。弗兰克·辛纳屈救了他的命。或者降落时飞机坠毁。在一座空军基地坠机降落？是的，一个戒备森严的空军基地。区域。是的。我觉得假的是坠机。我，但我猜它只有一半是假的。
This is my instinct. I think this thing with the lights did happen, and then I think the rest of it is a lie. Okay. I don't think there were alligators in the water, and I don't think that military people with Guns took him away in handcuffs. Also, he named the type of dogs. That was so specific. I think the plane crashes.
这是我的直觉。我觉得关于灯光的这件事确实发生了，然后我觉得剩下的部分是编的。好吧。我不觉得水里有短吻鳄，而且我也不觉得带枪的军人用手铐把他带走了。还有，他报出了狗的品种。这太具体了。我觉得坠机是假的。
Oh, God, I don't know because the guitar, like, he could know all that information. He has a ton of guitars if you go to his house. Yeah. He's got a wall of guitars. So he very well could have owned that guitar, but maybe it didn't come from a drug deal. All right. Do you have the answer? Wait, are we going to guess?
哦，天哪，我不知道，因为那把吉他，比如，他可能会知道所有这些信息。如果你去他家的话，他有一吨的吉他。是的。他有一整面墙的吉他。所以他完全有可能拥有那把吉他，但也许它不是来自毒品交易。好吧。你们有答案了吗？等等，我们要猜吗？
What's the lie? I said plane crash. You say plane crash. I'm going to say guitar. Okay. All right. We each picked a different one. Okay.
哪个是假的？我说坠机。你说是坠机。我说是吉他。好吧。我们各自选了不同的。好吧。
Here we go. He titled the last audio clip, I lied. Okay. The false one. The one I'm lying about is, wait for it. The 58 Gibson Korean Explorer. Nope. I never owned one of those.
我们来看答案。他把最后一段音频剪辑取名为“我撒谎了”。好吧。假的那一个。我在撒谎的那一个是，大家听好了。1958年的吉布森卡里娜探索者吉他。不对。我从来没有拥有过那样的吉他。
I've owned a Les Paul, 56, Black Beauty. 335, red Gibson, beautiful Gibson with a floating tailpiece. I now have a 69 blues bird and a 57 country and western. And a blues king, a very nice little parlor Gibson guitar. But no 58 Explorer, unfortunately. So there we go. I lied. Ha ha ha ha.
我曾拥有一把莱斯保尔，56年的黑色美丽（Black Beauty）。335，红色的吉布森，带浮动弦枕的美丽吉布森。我现在有一把69年的蓝鸟和一把57年的乡村与西方吉他。还有一把蓝调之王，一把非常漂亮的吉布森小型帕勒吉他。但遗憾的是，没有58年的探索者吉他。所以就是这样。我撒谎了。哈哈哈。
Do you all realize now what it's like to hang out with Creed? How long has he been sitting on this plane crash? story. I know. We've never heard this story. That, I mean, that's wild. So when he tells you a wild thing, you see why it might be true. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, I don't know. I just was like, there was, there was a few details in that plane story that I thought were so specific. That's why I thought it was half truth, half lie. Wow. Wow. Creed, you got me, but you didn't get Angela. Thanks, buddy. Well, now we're in Ned's office. He's half. He's half. having a meeting with Esmeralda and Ken.
你们现在意识到和克雷格一起玩是什么感觉了吗？他到底把这个坠机故事在心里憋了多久？我知道。我们从来没听过这个故事。那，我是说，太疯狂了。所以当他告诉你一件疯狂的事时，你就明白为什么它可能是真的了。是的，没错。是的，我不知道。我只是觉得，那个坠机故事里有几个细节我觉得太具体了。这就是为什么我认为它是半真半假。哇。哇。克雷格，你把我骗到了，但你没骗过安吉拉。谢谢你，伙计。好吧，现在我们在内德的办公室。他正在开会。
And he tells them, guys, we're doing pretty good, but we're one article short. Esmeralda pretends to be concerned. And she has a talking head. She's like, Ned is still here. He must have cockroach DNA. You know, it's like you smash it, but it doesn't die. And she does an impression of like a cockroach on its back with its legs wiggling. She does this thing with her hands.
他正在和埃斯梅拉达以及肯开会。他告诉他们：“伙计们，我们干得挺不错，但还差一篇稿子。”埃斯梅拉达假装很关切。她有一个单人独白。她说：“内德竟然还在。他身上一定有蟑螂的DNA。”你知道的，就像你把它拍扁了，但它就是不死。而且她还模仿了一只蟑螂四脚朝天、腿在蠕动的样子。她用手做了一个动作。
It's very funny. It's very funny. And she also has really long fingernails. Like, she's very expressive with her hands. Well, writer Patrick Kang said that when she did this bit where she pretends to be the cockroach, everybody went wild. Like, it was so funny. And he said that they discovered that she is particularly funny whenever she is talking about or impersonating animals or creatures. He said this was a big bonus, and you're going to see this more throughout the season because they started writing for it.
非常搞笑。真的很好笑。而且她还留着很长的指甲。比如，她用手势表达时非常生动。好吧，编剧帕特里克·康说，当她做这个模仿蟑螂的桥段时，所有人都疯狂了。真的太搞笑了。而且他说他们发现，每当她谈论或模仿动物或生物时，她就会格外搞笑。他说这是一个巨大的加分项，随着这一季的推进，你们会看到更多这样的场景，因为他们开始专门为这个写剧本了。
That is so funny. Well, Ken is going to suggest that they. They need their own version of wordal to keep, you know, people's minds off the actual news. Mm-hmm. And Mare has an idea. Esmeralda is so startled when Mare speaks up. Yeah, Mare is like sitting behind Esmeralda. Yeah.
太搞笑了。好吧，肯建议说，他们需要
And this is what I'm going to start calling Esmeralda Queen of Shade. And Shade Alert, number one, Esmeralda turns to Mare and says, Ah, I thought you were a pile of shirts. A pile of shirts. What a great line. Such good writing. That's such a good dig. Mare proposes that they resurrect this column from the 90s called Shame on You, where they uncover
他们自己版本的Wordle游戏，好让大家（的心思）从实际新闻上转移开。嗯哼。然后梅尔有个主意。埃斯梅拉达在梅尔开口时吓了一大跳。是的，梅尔就坐在埃斯梅拉达身后。是的。而这就是我要开始称呼埃斯梅拉达为“暗讽女王”的时候了。暗讽警报，第一号，埃斯梅拉达转过身对梅尔说：“啊，我还以为你是一堆衬衫呢。”一堆衬衫。多棒的一句台词。写得太好了。这讽刺得太妙了。梅尔提议他们复活一个90年代的专栏，叫作“真丢脸”（Shame on You），专门用来揭露本地企业的骗局。她说她最近去买过床垫，她认为本地的床垫店存在虚假广告骗局。内德兴奋极了。好吧，会议结束了，埃斯梅拉达气鼓鼓的。是的，她留到了最后。是的，她对内德喜欢梅尔的点子感到非常恼火。于是她决定搞点破坏，她就说：“哦，你知道吗，梅尔要去参加……”
a local business scam. She says she went shopping for a mattress recently, and she thinks that there's a false advertising scam at local mattress stores. Ned gets so excited. Well, the meeting's going to end, and Esmeralda is stewing. Yeah, she stays behind. Yeah, she's so annoyed that Ned likes Mare's ideas. is. So she decides to be sabotagey, and she's like, oh, you know what, Mayor's leaving for, you know,
一个酒店业务培训项目了。是的。她被丽笙酒店的礼宾培训项目录取了。内德听到这消息整个人都惊呆了。他说：“但她是我最好的记者。”他开始恐慌。我们迎来了“埃斯梅拉达讨厌鬼警报”，第二号。确实如此。她说：“梅尔，那个父母用一匹马的名字给她取名的女人。”是的。顺便问一句，你们注意到她的穿着了吗？我觉得这有点象征意义，你知道的，因为她是那个搞破坏的人。她系着一条蛇形腰带。在大约四分钟的时候有一个很好的特写镜头。所以它就像是一条宽宽的黑色腰带，但它的扣子是一条蜿蜒的金色毒蛇。哦。蛇形腰带。我喜欢。我查了一下。这种腰带有一大堆。如果你想要的话，你也可以来一条。你也可以拥有一条蛇形腰带。有太多版本的腰带扣是一条
a hotel business. Yeah. She got accepted to this concierge training program at the Radisson. Ned is, like, bummed out. He's like, but she's my best reporter. And he starts to panic. We have an Esmeraldehate alert, number two. We do. She says, Mayor, the woman whose parents named her after a horse. Yeah. Did you see her outfit, by the way? I thought it was symbolic. a little bit, you know, because she's the saboteur. She has on a snake belt. There's a great shot of it right around four minutes. So it's like this wide black belt, but then the buckle is this slithery gold snake. Oh. Snake belt. I like it. I looked it up. There's a gazillion of them. You can have one, too, if you want. You can have a snake belt. There's so many versions of it where the buckle is a
蛇的形状了。我不知道。我有点着迷了。你打算买一条蛇形腰带吗？我不知道。我是说，我可能会。你戴着蛇形腰带去参加什么场合？我想去哪就去哪。对吧？这是你的蛇形腰带。好吧，你知道的。
snake. I don't know. I got a little into it. Are you going to get a snake belt? I don't know. I mean, I might. What do you wear your snake belt to? Wherever I want. Right. It's your snake belt. Yeah. I mean, you know.
蛇。我不知道。我有点着迷了。你会买一条蛇皮腰带吗？我不知道。我的意思是，我可能会。你戴着蛇皮腰带去哪里？我想去哪就去哪。对。这是你的蛇皮腰带。是的。我的意思是，你知道的。
Well, Esmerald is not done being sabotaging. She also says that Mare is asexual. Yeah. She's going to call out Ned for what she perceives to be his crush on mayor. Yeah. All of this, like his admiration of her, his maybe crush on her, is all fueling just her need to take him down. Well, she doesn't want Mayor to be the superstar employee.
埃默拉尔德还没消停呢。她还说梅尔是无性恋。对。她要揭穿内德，因为她觉得内德对市长有意思。对。所有这些，比如他对他（她）的崇拜，他对她可能有的好感，都在助长她想要搞垮他的决心。好吧，她可不想让梅尔成为超级明星员工。
She's the superstar employee. Yes. Yeah. She's very jealous. Well, now Ned is going to approach Mayor in the copy room, and she says to him, what are the odds of this paper succeeding? Well, she's hedging her bets, right? Do I try to stick with it?
她才是超级明星员工。没错。是的。她嫉妒心很强。现在，内德要在复印室接近梅尔了，他对她说，这报纸成功的几率有多大？好吧，他这是在给自己留退路，对吧？我是该继续坚持下去呢？
Or do I leave and go work at this hotel? He says, he thinks their chance of succeeding is 95%. Yeah. And then Mayor has a talking hit. where she's like, that's delusional, right? And a little nerve-wracking because he holds my career in his hands. But then she wavers. She's like, but he did sell a crazy amount of toilet paper.
还是离开去这家酒店工作？他说，他觉得成功的几率是95%。然后梅尔有个单人访谈镜头，她说，这太不切实际了吧？而且有点让人紧张，因为他掌握着我的职业生涯。但接着她又动摇了。她说，不过他确实卖了惊人数量的厕纸。
Did you notice something about this talking head? Clearly you did. What is it? It's a two-angle talking head. Oh. The camera punches in. It goes from kind of a medium shot to a close-up midway through the talking head. And I was like, ooh, it's a new way.
你注意到这个单人访谈镜头的特别之处了吗？你肯定注意到了。是什么？这是一个双角度的单人访谈镜头。哦。镜头推进了。在访谈进行到一半时，画面从某种中景变成了特大特写。当时我想，哦，这是一种新方法。
Fancy. I mentioned earlier that this episode was directed by Yanna Gorskaya, who is new to the office directing universe. And in addition to this talking head, having this sort of like punch in, I noticed so many spy shots in this episode. Like she really used the spy shot. I feel like she got the documentary style and then she built on it. I just thought visually this episode was very interesting. And it's going to get even more interesting as we use these spy shots later. At the mattress store. Exactly.
真别致。我刚才提到过，这一集由亚娜·戈尔斯卡娅执导，她是《办公室》导演界的新人。除了这个单人访谈镜头有这种推进的效果外，我注意到这一集里有好多偷拍镜头。她真的用了好多偷拍镜头。我觉得她继承了纪录片风格，并在此基础上进行了创新。我觉得从视觉上看，这一集非常有趣。而且随着我们稍后在床垫店使用这些偷拍镜头，它会变得更有趣。在床垫店里。没错。
Yeah. No, I thought it was really cool. Well, Ned is so worried that Mayor is going to leave the company that he's decided he's going to stick with her for the day and do this mattress story with her. And Mayor says, great, we'll be Woodward and Woodward's boss. And immediately, Ned says, Ben Bradley. And Mayor's like, oh, of course you knew that. But then Ned is so giddy.
对。不，我觉得真的很酷。内德太担心梅尔会离开公司了，于是他决定今天一直陪着她，和她一起去这个床垫店。梅尔说，太好了，那我们就是伍德沃德和伍德沃德的老板了。内德马上说，本·布拉德利。梅尔说，哦，你当然知道了。但接着内德高兴得不得了。
He takes off running. And Mayor says, oh, you're really. run so athletically. Lady, did this remind you of anything? No. When he took off running like that, all I could think about was that scene in Friends when Rachel and Phoebe decided to go for a run, but Rachel has clearly never seen Phoebe run. And the way Lisa Kudrow runs as Phoebe is so hilarious. I do not remember this. Oh my God, it's such a great scene. I don't know which episode it's from, but when Ned took off running, all I could think of is I need to see he. him run more. I thought it was really funny physical comedy. Well, listen, lady, I think we should take a
他跑了起来。梅尔说，哦，你跑得还真有运动健将的风范。莱迪，这让我想起了什么吗？没有。当他那样跑起来的时候，我脑子里想的全是《老友记》里的那一集，瑞秋和菲比决定去跑步，但瑞秋显然从来没见过菲比跑步。丽莎·库卓演的菲比跑步的那个样子太搞笑了。我记不得了。哦，天哪，那真是一场精彩的戏。我不知道是哪一集里的，但当内德跑起来的时候，我脑子里想的全是我得看他再多跑跑。我觉得这是一个非常有趣的形体喜剧。好吧，听着，莱迪，我觉得我们应该休息一下。
break real quick. Yes. And when we come back, Nicole and Detrick are going to play two truths and a lie. And I'm going to need to have a conversation with you about gas station sushi. Okay, we are back. And now we're in the bullpen. And Detrick goes and sits opposite Nicole because they have clearly been paired up. They're supposed to play two truths and a lie. Mm-hmm. He's going to offer her some sushi, and she says, where'd you get that sushi? There's no sushi around here. And he says, oh, I hate to disagree with you right off the bat, but they have it at the gas station. And Nicole goes, ew. Jenna. What? Would you eat gas station sushi? No. Would you? I know. But there is a Reddit thread about this very topic. Gas station sushi? Yes, whether you should eat it or not. And really, there's a few different views here.
马上回来。是的。等我们回来后，妮可和迪特里克要玩“两真一假”的游戏。我还得跟你聊聊加油站寿司的事。好的，我们回来了。现在我们在开敞式办公区。迪特里克走到妮可对面坐下，因为他们显然被分到了一组。他们要玩“两真一假”的游戏。嗯哼。他要给她一些寿司，而她说，你从哪弄的寿司？这附近可没有寿司。他说，哦，一上来就想反驳你，不过加油站有卖的。妮可说，呃。珍娜。什么？你会吃加油站寿司吗？不会。你会吗？我知道。不过有一个关于这个话题的红迪网帖子。加油站寿司？是的，关于你该不该吃。真的，这里有几种不同的观点。
I want to read three to you. Okay. One person said, taste and quality is just not the same as what you'd get from a good sushi place or making your own with quality ingredients, but gas station sushi is not the worst pre-packaged. Someone else said, what country?
我想读三条给你听。好的。一个人说，味道和质量确实比不上你在好的寿司店吃到的，或者自己用优质食材做的，但加油站寿司也不是预包装里最差的。另一个人说，哪个国家？
That's a deciding factor. Oh, that is the deciding factor. They go on to say 7-Eleven sushi in Japan is not bad. Oh. And then lastly, someone says, again, coming here to say, it depends on where you get it from, sometimes it's great. Sometimes it's like a whole tuna fish farted and shit in your face. I'm so sorry, if you ever purchased gas station sushi that tasted like a tuna fish farted in your face,
这是决定性因素。哦，这确实是决定性因素。他接着说，日本的7-11寿司并不赖。哦。最后，有人说，再次说明，这取决于你在哪买的，有时它棒极了。有时它就像整条金枪鱼放了个屁，还拉在你脸上。非常抱歉，如果你买过吃起来像金枪鱼放屁在你脸上的加油站寿司，
why would you ever buy it again? I don't think. Like, why do they keep going back? I don't think this person went back, right? I don't know. They say sometimes it's good, sometimes it's bad. You're right. That confuses me.
你为什么还会再买？我不认为。怎么说呢，他们为什么还要回去买？我觉得这个人没回去买吧？我不知道。他们说有时候好，有时候坏。你说得对。这把我搞糊涂了。
That's right. You're right. They've tried it a few times. Anyway, what I learned from this Reddit thread is it really depends what country and where you are at what gas station. Let me tell you what gas stations are for. Gas. Gas. A bag of chips.
没错。你说得对。他们试了好几次。不管怎样，我从这个红迪网帖子学到的是，这真的取决于哪个国家，取决于你在哪个加油站。让我告诉你加油站到底是用来干什么的。汽油。汽油。一包薯片。
Maybe a hot dog, maybe a hot coffee. they are not for sushi, fruit. Fruit? I've had a good banana from a gas station. Have you? Have you? Yes. Quality banana.
也许还有热狗，热咖啡。它们可不是用来卖寿司和水果的。水果？我在加油站吃过不错的香蕉。是吗？真的吗？是的。优质香蕉。
Okay. Listen, I'm with you. I'm not going to do uncooked raw fish from a gas station. But I'll get a banana there. I think gas stations are for processed food. That's the food you want to buy at a gas station. Maybe a banana. A long shelf life.
好吧。听着，我和你站一边。我不会在加油站买没煮过的生鱼。但我会在那买根香蕉。我觉得加油站就是卖加工食品的地方。那才是你想在加油站买的食物。也许还有根香蕉。保质期长。
All right. And then that's it. We're almost on the same page. A water. Minus the banana we're on the same page. A soda. Okay. You know? The other thing I clocked in this scene that I want to talk about is all of the birds.
好啦，就这样。我们俩意见差不多。一瓶水。除了香蕉，我们俩完全一致。一打苏打水。好吧。你知道吗？我在这个场景中注意到的另一件事，我想谈谈，那就是所有的鸟。
There's so many birds at Nicole's desk. Yeah. There's like a bird on the wall. There's little bird figurines. There's so many chotchkes. If Angela Martin was the cat lady, Nicole is the bird lady. Well, we're about to find out where Ned ran off to. It's to Oscar's desk to ask him to whip up another.
妮可的桌上有好多鸟。对。墙上有只鸟。还有小鸟摆件。有好多小玩意儿。如果安吉拉·马丁是猫咪女士，那妮可就是鸟类女士。好了，我们马上要揭晓内德跑到哪去了。他去了奥斯卡的桌子，让他赶紧再弄出个。
Sudoku, just in case he and mayor don't make their deadline for the mattress story. He can throw that in. Oscar does say to Ned that this type of pressure is giving him PTSD from an old boss. Any guesses who that is? Did you see what's right behind Oscar over his shoulder? Yes, it's the scarecrow. The homemade scarecrow doll that Michael Scott gave him. But I also caught something else.
数独，以防他和梅尔赶不上床垫报道的截稿时间。他可以把这个加进去。奥斯卡确实对内德说过，这种压力让他对以前的老板产生了创伤后应激障碍。猜猜那是谁？你看到奥斯卡肩膀后面的那个东西了吗？是的，就是稻草人。迈克尔·斯科特送给他的那个自制稻草人玩偶。但我还发现了别的东西。
It is a framed picture of Oscar's dog Gus. Oh, his real dog. Yes. So Gus was his dog while we filmed the office. Gus has since passed, but that picture of Gus in that frame was the same one that was on his desk in the office. And I actually reached out to Oscar, and I was like, Oscar, am I losing it? But I'm pretty sure that's Gus in the frame, the same one you had when we filmed, you know, at the Dundra Mifflin set. And he said, it is.
那是一张奥斯卡的狗古斯的框画。哦，他真正的狗。对。所以古斯在我们拍摄《办公室》的时候就是他的狗。古斯后来去世了，但相框里的那张古斯的照片和他在办公室桌上的那张一模一样。我其实联系了奥斯卡，我说，奥斯卡，我是不是疯了？但我很确定那就是相框里的古斯，和你当年在邓德米夫林片场拍摄时桌上的一模一样。他说，是的。
Isn't that nice? So there are two things there from Oscar's original desk that have made it into the paper. I love that. Well, now we're in the parking lot of the mattress store. and Mare and Ned are discussing what are their alter egos? Like, what kind of couple are we going to be as we shop for this mattress undercover? I mean, this is totally mom detectives lady. When I watched this scene, it was cracking me up because it made me think of me and you
这不是很棒吗？所以奥斯卡原办公桌上有两样东西出现在了报纸上。我太喜欢了。好了，现在我们在床垫店的停车场。梅尔和内德在讨论他们的化身是什么？比如，我们以卧底身份去买床垫时，会扮演什么样的情侣？我的天，这完全是妈妈侦探啊，莱迪。我看这场戏的时候笑得不行，因为它让我想起了你和我。
undercover trying to figure out what was the windowless building in my neighborhood. Yeah. I have an audio clip of their discussion in the car because I loved it so much. Okay, so what kind of couple should we be? Just a regular couple. Not regular. Hetero. Ciss?
曾经为了查明我社区里那个没有窗户的建筑物是什么而去做卧底。对。我有一段他们在车里讨论的音频剪辑，因为我太喜欢了。好吧，那我们应该扮演什么样的情侣？就普通情侣吧。不是普通情侣。异性恋。顺性别？
What do you ask? No, I just mean, are we boozy, you know, or are we cheap? Are we too online? Are we not online at all in a way that's kind of weird, you know? Do we have kids? Do you want kids and I don't? It's kind of tearing us apart.
你问什么呢？不，我的意思是，我们是那种爱喝酒的，你知道的，还是抠门的？我们是网上冲浪过度的人？还是那种怪里怪气的完全不上网的人？我们有孩子吗？你想要孩子而我不想要？这把我们的关系撕裂了。
If this is making you at all uncomfortable, we don't have to be a couple at all. All right? We can just be brother and sister. We're buying a mattress together? Our mom gets debilitating bladder infections. She's incontinence. Oh, my God.
如果这让你感到哪怕一点点不舒服，我们完全不用装成情侣。好吧？我们演兄妹就行了。我们一起买床垫？我妈有严重的膀胱感染。她尿失禁。哦，天哪。
Oh, my God. We're just a couple. Okay? And keep the mom thing in your back pocket if everything goes wrong. I am so sorry to hear about your mother. Thanks. Thank you. It's his mother.
哦，天哪。我们就是一对情侣。好吧？如果一切搞砸了，把妈的事留作后手。听到你母亲的事我很难过。谢谢。谢谢。那是他妈。
We're actually married. I'm also her boss. I love how it cuts to them in the mattress store. And he has already talked about this mother. She's like, keep it in your back pocket. And it's clearly what he led with. Well, I have a fun thing from Clarissa in Austin, Texas. Ladies, this isn't a question, more of a comment.
其实我们结婚了。我还是她老板。我太喜欢切到他们在床垫店里的镜头了。他已经提过这个母亲了。她还说，留作后手。而这显然是他一开口就抛出来的话。好吧，我有一个来自得克萨斯州奥斯汀的克丽丝塔的好玩的东西。女士们，这不是一个问题，更像是一个评论。
When I was watching the scene with Mare and Ned, before they go into the mattress store, it made me think of suit warehouse where Dwight and Jim say they used to do calls as brothers, and Dwight says they were Jim and Dwight Shrewpert. Oh, yeah. Isn't that cute? That's super cute. I know. I love those scenes, too.
当我看到梅尔和内德在他们进床垫店之前的场景时，让我想起了西装仓库那一集，德怀特和吉姆说他们以前打电话时扮演兄弟，德怀特说他们叫吉姆和德怀特·施鲁珀特。哦，对。是不是很可爱？超级可爱。我知道。我也很喜欢那些场景。
Well, lady, I just remember your big idea. when we were going to be mom detectives to figure out what was going on in the windowless building. Do you remember it? Because it was very funny. No, I don't. You said that the way we get into the building is that we should deliver them like a fruit basket or some flowers. And you were like, I was like, what? We're going to take a fruit basket in? I'm like, no, we're just going to walk in. Just walk in. Let's just go. And you're like, no, we need a reason. We need. We need. a thing. We need a cover.
好了，莱迪，我还记得你的那个宏大主意。当时我们要当妈妈侦探去查清楚那个无窗建筑里到底在干什么。你还记得吗？因为那太搞笑了。不，我不记得了。你说我们进入那栋大楼的方法应该是给他们送个果篮或者一些鲜花。然后你说，我说，什么？我们要带个果篮进去？我说，不，我们直接走进去。直接走进去。我们走吧。然后你说，不，我们需要一个理由。我们需要。我们需要。一个借口。我们需要一个掩护。
And then you walked in. We walked in together and you were like, hey. And then you went blank. There was like this weird moment and this guy is just looking at us. And then finally you're like, we're just wondering, what is this place? You just asked him. I was like, let's not beat around the bush. There were some clues as we walked up the ramp to get inside.
然后你就走进去了。我们一起走了进去，你说，嘿。然后你就卡壳了。当时有一种很诡异的时刻，这个家伙就看着我们。最后你终于说，我们只是想知道，这是什么地方？你直接问了他。我说，咱们别拐弯抹角了。当我们走坡道进去的时候有一些线索。
There were some elderly people having some sunshine. Yeah. But still. Yeah. Yeah. It was very clear people there were of a certain age. Yeah. Yeah. Why are you dancing around it? I don't know. The thing I found most interesting, though, is that he said we're a senior center. And I was like, yeah, ding, ding, ding. And he goes, but we also rent it out for weddings.
有一些老年人在晒太阳。对。但还是。对。对。很明显那里的都是一定年龄的人。对。对。你为什么还要绕弯子呢？我不知道。不过我觉得最有趣的是，他说我们是个高级活动中心。当时我就想，耶，宾果。他说，但我们也把场地租出去办婚礼。
No, he did not. Is that true? That back room where they were like playing cards and stuff. You can also rent that out. I missed that. Oh, yeah. How did I miss that? I don't know. You were jotting something down on your notepad that you had. But he said you can also, you know, sometimes we do like events, you know, like wedding receptions, things like that. That's fascinating to me. I feel like I need to go back. Also, by the way, it wasn't a live-in facility. So that makes sense. During the day, it was just a daytime facility for elderly people to go to. A senior center. Right, where they can go play cards or bridge or they'll have someone come in like.
不，他才没说。真的吗？他们打牌什么的那个后房间。那个也可以租出去。我漏掉了。哦，对。我怎么漏掉了？我不知道。你当时正在你带的记事本上写写画画。但他说你也可以，你知道的，有时我们也会办活动，比如婚宴之类的。这太吸引人了。我觉得我得回去一趟。另外，顺便说一句，这不是一个长期住宿的设施。所以这就说得通了。白天，它只是一个供老年人去的日间活动设施。高级活动中心。没错，他们可以在那打牌、打桥牌，或者会有人来做。
But there's nurses in physical therapy there too. Yes. Right. But that room where they play cards and stuff. At night. You could also have your, you know. What a business model. Wedding reception.
但那里也有护士和物理治疗师。是的。没错。但他们打牌的那个房间。晚上。你也可以用来办你的，你知道的。多么棒的商业模式。婚宴。
Hmm. All right. Well, now they're inside of the mattress store. And they're talking to Cindy, the mattress store employee. And they ask about a particular mattress. And she says, oh, this one's great. It's $1,900. And Ned is like, well, you know what?
嗯。好了，现在他们进到床垫店里面了。他们在和床垫店员工辛迪说话。他们问起一款特定的床垫。她说，哦，这款很棒。1900美元。内德就说，好吧，你知道吗？
You guys have like a price match guarantee, right? I was down at this other mattress store, and I saw this mattress for 1450. Would you honor that price? And she's like, oh, no, you didn't see this mattress because this is exclusive to our store. And he's like, really, it looks like the same mattress. Could you go check? This is part of the scam. Mm-hmm.
你们有价格匹配保证对吧？我在另一家床垫店看到这款床垫卖1450。你们能按这个价格卖给我吗？她说，哦，不，你绝对没见过这款床垫，因为这是我们店独家专卖的。他说，真的吗，看起来像是一样的床垫。你能去查一下吗？这是骗局的一部分。嗯哼。
Guess what? This whole storyline is based on a true story from Greg Daniels' life. Greg Daniels was trying to find a mattress that he loved. and he was trying to buy it again because he loved it, but he needed a new one. So he couldn't find it. This is when he uncovered the truth. The truth, which is that mattress stores do this. They have exclusive names for the exact same mattresses so that you can't compare prices.
你猜怎么着？整个故事情节取材于格雷格·丹尼尔斯生活中的真实故事。格雷格·丹尼尔斯当时想找一张他特别喜欢的床垫。他想再买一张，因为他太喜欢了，但他需要一张新的。所以他找不到。这就是他发现真相的时候。真相就是，床垫店就是这么干的。他们对完全相同的床垫起不同的独家名字，这样你就没法比价了。
I looked it up, lady, there are a gazillion, gazillion Reddit threads and websites dedicated to decoding all of the names for all these mattresses that are actually the same mattress. Wow. Mm-hmm. Yeah. And I feel like it made its way into this episode as Greg's little way of exposing this to the world. He's like, I got you. Yeah.
我查过了，莱迪，有无数个、无数个红迪网帖子和网站，专门用来破解这些其实是同一款床垫的所有名字。哇。嗯哼。是的。我觉得它能进到这一集里，是格雷格向世界揭露这件事的小小方式。他就像是说，我抓到你们了。耶。
I got your number. This is his expose. Yeah. Well, I did ask Mary, who plays Cindy, if they filmed in a real mattress store or if that was a set they built. And here's what she said. She said, yep, it was a real mattress store. So at lunch, I just went ahead and laid down. Wow, that's amazing.
我摸清你们的底了。这就是他的曝光。好吧，我确实问过饰演辛迪的玛丽，他们是在真正的床垫店拍的，还是搭的景。她是这么说的。她说，是的，那真的是一家床垫店。所以在午饭时，我直接就躺下了。哇，太棒了。
She also said that everyone she met that day was so lovely. There was no ego, no tension, just really funny pros on and off screen. She also said a crew can really make the set feel cozy. And for a guest star who's in for one day, it's so lovely to be greeted by everyone so warmly. I felt like family, even though it was just for the day. And then she had one other thing I want to share about shooting these big scenes. there are big scenes in this huge room, right? She said, I had never shot a documentary-style TV show.
她还说她那天遇到的人都太可爱了。没有自我，没有紧张，无论镜头内外都是非常有趣专业的演员。她还说剧组能让片场感觉非常温馨。对于一个只拍一天的客串演员来说，受到每个人如此热烈的欢迎真是太美妙了。我觉得就像一家人一样，尽管只待了一天。然后她还有一件事想分享，关于拍摄这些大场面。在这个巨大的房间里有很大的场面，对吧？她说，我从来没拍过纪录片风格的电视剧。
So it actually didn't dawn on me when we were filming for real. She didn't know where the cameras were. She didn't know they were filming until they wrapped her first scene. She said, I'm so used to cameras being really invasive. You know, they're right there where you can see them with cords and lights all around. And she said, I didn't know where the cameras were until one of the grips started a la Dear Evan Hansen style waving through the window, way over here. We're over here.
所以我们在真拍的时候，我其实根本没意识到。她不知道摄像机在哪里。直到她拍完第一场戏，她都不知道他们在拍。她说，我太习惯那种极具侵入性的摄像机了。你知道的，它们就在你能看到的地方，周围全是线和灯。她说，直到其中一个场务学着《埃文·汉森致敬》的风格，在老远老远那边的窗户外面挥手，我们在那边。我们在那边。
Wow. Yeah, because she was like, are we filming? Like, where are the cameras? That's how far away the cameras were. And that's what you were talking about. Yeah, the super spy shot. Yeah, that the director was creating this very cool vibe on this set that you didn't even see the cameras.
哇。是的，因为她当时想，我们在拍吗？摄像机在哪？摄像机离得就是这么远。这就是你刚才说的那样。是的，超级偷拍镜头。导演在这个片场营造了这种超酷的氛围，让你甚至都看不到摄像机。
Mm-hmm. Well, now we're going to go into this meeting. Marv is running this meeting. It's with Esmeralda, Ken, and Oscar, and there's supposed to be a fourth person there. Ned, he's missing. He's missing. I called these scenes
嗯。好了，现在我们要进入这场会议了。这场会议由马尔夫主持。参会人员有埃斯梅拉达、肯和奥斯卡，本来应该还有第四个人的。内德，他不见了。他不见了。我把这些场景叫做
Big Boardroom Budget Meeting. Oh, Ken calls it bi-weekly budget meeting. But I like your name, too. Big Boardroom Budget Meeting. Well, we're just not in this big boardroom very often, and it looks prestigious. It looks like a place where important things happen.
“大会议室预算会议”。哦，肯管它叫“双周预算会议”。不过我也喜欢你的名字，大会议室预算会议。嗯，我们其实不常在这个大会议室开会，而且它看起来很高档。看起来像是个会发生重要事情的地方。
Yeah, this is on another floor. This is on the executive level. This is Marv's world. That's right. Well, Esmerald is just going to continue to throw Ned under the bus. Yeah, she's super sabotaging in this scene. She's making him seem incompetent. Like, she says I told him about the meeting.
对，这在另一层楼。这是在行政层。这是马尔夫的世界。没错。嗯，埃斯梅拉达又要开始把内德推出去当替罪羊了。对，她在这个场景里简直是在极力破坏。她把内德说得好像很不称职。比如，她说我告诉过他开会的事。
But what she did was she put a little sticky note that says M-O-B, M-I-A-B. On his computer, yes. Which I guess means Marv's office budget meeting in a bit. And, you know, of course he didn't know what that was. Right. But she's going to tell Marv, oh, I told him about the meeting. Yeah. I left him a note.
但她实际做的只是贴了一张小便签，上面写着“M-O-B，M-I-A-B”。贴在他的电脑上，对。我猜这意思是“马尔夫办公室预算会议，待会儿见”。而且，当然啦，他根本不知道那是什么意思。没错。但她打算告诉马尔夫，哦，我告诉过他开会的事。对。我给他留了便条。
She doesn't tell him she left a note saying mob meab. I love that you took on pronouncing it. Now we're back at Nicole and Detrick's desks. And they're doing some would you rather questions to try to learn about one another. Yeah, they say, would you rather be able to speak to animals or speak any human language ever that you ever wanted to speak? I want us to answer this question. I have it too. I said, Jenna, what do you pick?
她可没告诉马尔夫她留的便条上写的是“mob meab”。我太喜欢你发这个音了。现在我们回到了妮可和迪特里克的办公桌旁。他们在玩“你更愿意”的游戏，试图借此了解彼此。对，他们说，你更愿意能够和动物对话，还是能够说出你想说的任何人类语言？我想让我们也回答这个问题。我也准备了。我说，珍娜，你选哪个？
This is really hard for me. I don't know. Because they're both really good. This is a very good, would you rather. Is this the best, would you rather question? Like, is it the best? In the history of would you rather? Maybe.
这对我来说真的很难。我不知道。因为这两个听起来都很棒。这是一个非常棒的“你更愿意”问题。这难道不是最棒的“你更愿意”问题吗？比如说，它是最棒的吗？在“你更愿意”的历史上？也许吧。
Maybe. Because I feel like every time I hear a would you rather question. And also because it's a would you rather that isn't like gross or harmful. Yeah. It's this is like. Two skill sets that could be cool. Yes. I know my answer immediately.
也许吧。因为我觉得每次我听到“你更愿意”的问题时。而且因为这是一个既不低俗也不具伤害性的“你更愿意”问题。对。这就好比。是两种很酷的技能。是的。我马上就知道我的答案是什么了。
What is it? I would rather be able to speak any human language ever. Here's the thing. I have a lot of bird feeders. Oh, you don't want all that chatter? I don't know if I need. Like, move over, move over. It's my turn.
是什么？我更愿意能够说任何人类语言。问题是这样的。我有很多鸟类喂食器。哦，你可不想要那种叽叽喳喳的声音？我不知道我是不是需要。比如，让开，让开。轮到我了。
It's my turn. I don't know if I need to know all that. You're right. The world would be very loud if you could hear all animals and all humans. Yeah. I think about my two. crazy chihuahua mixed rescues. Biscuit every day, we have this joke in our family where I say every day she has this
轮到我了。我不知道我是不是需要听懂所有那些声音。你说得对。如果你能听懂所有动物和所有人类的声音，世界会变得非常吵闹。对。我想到了我的两只。脾气暴躁的吉娃娃混血救援犬。饼干（Biscuit），每天我们家都有个笑话，我说它每天都有
this like sort of passion she wakes up with. Like I feel like if Biscuit could like get us to all gather around, she'd say something like this. Listen, that asshole's going to come to the door today. He's going to say he has a package. That's bullshit. We're going to fucking go out of them. We're going to go out of everything we got.
这种它醒来时自带的激情。就好像我觉得如果饼干能让我们大家都围过来，它会说这样的话。听着，那个混蛋今天要来按门铃。他会说他有个包裹。那是扯淡。我们要冲过去。我们要倾尽所有冲出去。
Who's with me? That's Biscuit's synergy every morning. Like the minute I opened the door, she's like, hey, you motherfuckers! Don't you come on this yard? You know, now that you've broken it down, I take back what I said about this being the best. Would you rather? Because I was going to pick animals, but you totally 100% dissuaded me from that choice. I'm going to go with the other one than any human language.
谁跟我一起上？这就是饼干每天早上的凝聚力。就像我一开门，它就会说，嘿，你们这群混蛋！不准踏上这个院子！你知道的，经你这么一分析，我收回我刚才说这是最棒的“你更愿意”问题的话。因为我本来要选动物的，但你完全百分之百地打消了我那个选择。我要选另一个，任何人类语言。
I wish you could pick and choose the animal, you know, or when to turn it on. Right. You know, maybe if I was whale watching and like some amazing humpback well came up to the surface, I might say, dude, how are you doing, man? You know? Maybe I want to hear what that humpback whale says. I don't need to hear what my crazy chihuahua mix says every day, all day. Let me bring it down. This is going to get a little somber.
我希望你能挑选和指定动物，你知道的，或者知道什么时候开启这个功能。对。你知道的，也许如果我在观鲸，有些惊艳的座头鲸浮出水面，我可能会说，老兄，最近怎么样？你知道吗？也许我想听听那头座头鲸说些什么。我可不需要整天每时每刻都听我那只疯狂的吉娃娃混血狗说些什么。让我收回情绪。接下来要变得有点忧郁了。
Oh. What if you or a veterinarian or something? could speak to animals when they're in distress or before they're passing, you could tell them everything you loved about that you could share that back and forth, that comfort, you know? What about that? What about those moments in pet ownership? What a gift that would be.
哦。如果你或兽医之类的。能够在动物痛苦时或临终前与它们对话，你可以告诉它们你有多爱它们，你们可以来回分享这种安慰，你知道吗？那这个呢？宠物主人经历的那些时刻呢？那将是多么珍贵的礼物啊。
Well, I mean, yeah, I mean, it'd be nice to comfort them, wouldn't it? Yes. But the trade-off is you're also going to have to listen to them all the time. Right? So this is a different would you rather. This is like, would you rather be able to know what animals are saying and be able to communicate with them all the time, or would you rather pick and choose when you? I'm just saying there's a benefit to being able to speak to animals,
好吧，我是说，对，安慰它们当然很好，不是吗？是的。但代价是你也得一直听它们唠叨。对吧？所以这是另一个“你更愿意”的问题。这就好比，你更愿意随时知道动物在说什么并能与它们交流，还是更愿意自己挑选和决定什么时候……我只是说能和动物对话有好处，
but there's probably more benefit in being able to speak any human language ever. That's it. That's where we land. That's where we've landed. Well, listen, Nicole's going to say. talk to animals. And so is Detrick. And then this leads her to talking about her pet bird Cardi Beak. And then that leads to her revealing that she got said pet bird from a guy she was dating and he was a married guy. And then she gets really ashamed that she shared so much. Yeah. I think, you know,
但能够说任何人类语言可能好处更多。就是这样。这就是我们的结论。这就是我们的定论。好吧，听着，妮可会说。和动物对话。迪特里克也是。然后这引出了她谈论自己的宠物鸟“卡迪喙”（Cardi Beak）。接着这又让她透露说，这只宠物鸟是她以前约会过的一个男人送的，而那个男人是个已婚男。然后她为自己分享了这么多而感到非常羞愧。对。我觉得，你知道，
Detrick jokes was the bird the last straw. And she says, no, it was his wife. And that's awkward. Right. Yeah. Yeah. And she walked. away. And he's like, what just happened? He didn't know. Yeah. Cardi Beak is a great name for a bird. It is a great name for a bird. I love anytime people do that. Anytime people do what? Like kind of have a pun on a name like that. Like Isabel's fifth grade class had a plant and they named it Keanu leaves. Okay. Okay. That was so cute. Anyway, okay. Up next, I want to talk about a scene. Now, this scene was in the peacock version. It's not in the NBC broadcast version.
迪特里克开玩笑说，这只鸟是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草吗？她说，不，是他老婆。这就很尴尬了。对。没错。然后她走。开了。而他则是一脸“刚刚发生了什么”？他根本不知道。对。卡迪喙（Cardi Beak）是个给鸟起的好名字。这确实是个给鸟起的好名字。我喜欢任何人这么做。任何人做什么？比如名字里带点双关语什么的。就像伊莎贝尔五年级的班里有一株植物，他们把它叫做“基努·叶斯”（Keanu leaves）。好吧。好吧。那太可爱了。不管怎样，好吧。接下来，我想聊一个场景。现在，这个场景出现在孔雀（Peacock）版本里。它不在全国广播公司（NBC）的播出版里。
But basically, we're back in the big boardroom budget meeting. Yep. And we get to meet Anne. It seems as if she's maybe Marv's longtime secretary. Mm-hmm. And Marv is getting really worked up. The longer Ned isn't there, he's starting to get riled up. And I loved this scene between Marvin Ann.
但基本上，我们回到了大会议室预算会议。是的。我们见到了安。看起来她可能是马尔夫的长期秘书。嗯哼。马尔夫开始变得非常激动。内德越是不在，他就越开始烦躁。我太喜欢马尔夫和安之间的这个场景了。
I'm really rooting for Marvin Ann. If any of the writers are listening, can we please have more Marvin Ann? And I want you guys to hear this. Where the heck is this guy? I'm starting to get worked up. Don't get worked up, Marv. Anne's right. I'm not going to get worked up. Let's get him on the phone. Ann?
我真的非常支持马尔夫和安。如果有任何编剧在听的话，求求你们多写一点马尔夫和安的戏好吗？我想让你们听听这个。这家伙到底去哪儿了？我开始火大了。别上火，马尔夫。安说得对。我才不上火呢。给他打电话。安？
Yes, Marfan. I think we should start. Nad is so gifted a delegate into me. Let's start. False humor, man. Oh, well, it was time for me to stretch my legs anyway, so... You okay? Yeah, fuck, good. She comes bustling down this long hallway.
在的，马尔夫。我觉得我们应该开始了。内德把任务委托给我了，他太有天赋了。我们开始吧。虚惊一场，天哪。哦，好吧，反正我也该活动活动腿脚了，所以……你没事吧？对，他妈的，挺好。她快步走过这条长长的走廊。
And then when he's like false alarm, Anne, I just love that she was like, well, it's time to stretch my legs anyway. It's just their whole dynamic is wonderful and just so great. And I love how he's like, are you okay? Like, how's it going? I think Marv just wants to hang out with Anne. They're like an old married couple a little bit. 100%.
然后当他说“虚惊一场，安”，我太喜欢她说的那句“好吧，反正我也该活动活动腿脚了”。他们的整体化学反应简直太棒了，实在太棒了。我喜欢他说“你还好吗？最近怎么样？”我猜马尔夫只是想和安待在一起。他们有点像老夫老妻。百分之百。
Well, shout out to Nancy Lynn Hahn, who plays Anne. Guess what? She was also in two episodes of How I Met Your Mother. Crossover Connection. Well, now we're going to go back to the mattress store, and Cindy is still in the back. She's clearly gone back in the back to, quote, talk to her manager and is hoping that Mayor and Ned will just leave. So while they're waiting for Cindy, Ned starts snooping around her desk, and he discovers the name of the mattress supplier on the desk. And they're like, should we call it?
好吧，向饰演安的南希·琳恩·汉（Nancy Lynn Hahn）致敬。你猜怎么着？她还出演过两集《老爸老妈浪漫史》。跨界联动。好了，现在我们要回到那家床垫店，辛迪还在后间。她显然是去了后间去“跟经理谈谈”，并希望马尔和内德能直接离开。所以在等辛迪的时候，内德开始在她的桌子周围搜寻，他在桌上发现了床垫供应商的名字。他们就在想，我们要打个电话吗？
Let's call it. And he does this brilliant thing. He calls, and clearly the person on the other line is like, Cindy? And he says, no, no, this is Ned. I'm calling from Cindy's desk. She's in the back. Yeah. But I was wondering if you could cross-reference the various mattress names for the model number that I have.
打个电话吧。然后他做了一件绝妙的事。他打了过去，电话那头的人显然以为是辛迪？他说，不，不，我是内德。我用辛迪的桌子打电话。她在后间。对。不过我想知道你能不能帮我查一下，用我手头的型号去对比各种床垫的名字。
And they do it. Basically, they expose the scam. Jackpot, they're so excited. The two of them do this dance for joy. It's so cute. It's so cute. I did feel like Ned's dance was a little Ed. Grimley? Very Ed Grimley. But this was really exciting to me. I was rooting for them to have a good
他们照做了。基本上，他们揭穿了这场骗局。中大奖了，他们兴奋极了。他们两个高兴得跳起舞来。太可爱了。真的太可爱了。我确实觉得内德跳的舞有点像埃德。格林利（Ed Grimley）？非常像埃德·格林利。但这让我感到非常兴奋。我一直支持他们能有一篇好
article. You know, this is our third episode in the series now. And this is kind of the first win for the paper. Yeah. Don't you feel like that? Yeah, for sure. I was happy for them too. And of course, when Cindy does eventually come back, they confront her. They say, we're from the truth teller doing a report on consumer protection. And she's like, I knew your mother wasn't sick. And then basically she's like, I'm not going to say anything. You have no proof. And then they point to the cameras. Yes. They say, actually, we do have proof. Here is one camera. Here's another camera. And they call out the camera person's name Mandy. Mandy. Mandy is their real B camera operator. Mandy Whitaker. I thought so. I thought they were just looking right at their friend behind the camera.
文章。你知道，这是我们剧集的第三集了。这算是报社的第一次胜利。对。你不这么觉得吗？对，当然。我也为他们感到高兴。当然，当辛迪最终回来时，他们与她对质。他们说，我们是“说真话者”报社的，正在做一篇关于消费者保护的报道。而她则说，我就知道你妈没生病。然后基本上她说，我什么都不会说。你们没有任何证据。接着他们指向了摄像头。是的。他们说，其实，我们确实有证据。这是第一个摄像头。这是第二个摄像头。他们喊出了摄像师的名字曼迪（Mandy）。曼迪。曼迪就是他们真正的B机摄像师。曼迪·惠特克（Mandy Whitaker）。我也这么觉得。我还以为他们只是在看摄像机后面的朋友呢。
Mandy has also done camera operating on St. Dennis Medical, and it's always sunny in Philadelphia. Well, Cindy sees the cameras, and she's like, whatever, fine. I'll give it up. And I thought Mary did such a great job in this moment as Cindy, and I want you guys to hear it. All right. Oh, no. I actually hate this job. Oh. I hate this stupid polo that they make you pay for yourself. I was too scared to be a geologist, and now it's too late. So get your notepads out. Let's burn it all down.
曼迪也曾在《圣丹尼斯医疗》和《费城永远阳光灿烂》担任过摄像。好吧，辛迪看到了摄像机，然后她想，随便吧，好吧。我招了。我觉得玛丽（Mary）在演辛迪这个时刻表现得太棒了，我想让你们听听这个。好吧。哦，不。其实我讨厌这份工作。哦。我讨厌这件他们让你自己掏钱买的愚蠢Polo衫。我当年太害怕而不敢成为地质学家，现在已经太迟了。所以把你们的记事本拿出来。让我们把这一切都烧成灰烬。
Let's get some water. And then we can get into it. I'll help. Why don't we get some water? I'm going to write it too. We're all good. I'll write it. Let's burn it all down, lady.
我们去弄点水。然后我们就可以开始了。我来帮忙。我们怎么不去弄点水？我也要写。我们都很好。我来写。让我们把一切都烧个精光吧，女士。
Cindy would make a great guest on Office Ladies Burn It to the ground. That's what I thought. She's ready to talk. I mean, she's just so good. I thought she was great. Yeah, she played it perfectly. and we were trading emails about it. And she said, and I was reminded of a conversation we had at an Emmy party.
辛迪会是《办公室女士》播客“烧个精光”栏目的绝佳嘉宾。我也是这么想的。她随时准备好畅谈了。我是说，她实在是太棒了。我觉得她演得太好了。对，她完美地演绎了这一幕。我们为此交换了电子邮件。她说，这让我想起了我们在艾美奖派对上的一次对话。
And I was like, which one? And she said, so it was the night before party in 2024. She said, I was headed to film the paper that week, and you gave me some great advice. You said, quote, don't be the funny guy. And if you think you can make it even smaller, do. Oh, you kind of gave her the direction that Ken Kwapis gave you. Exactly. And she said, so I just told the story, and I'm so glad I did. She said, I thought it made me funnier. And she said, it's a really big set. And in my nervous actor brain, I could have absolutely overshot and overplayed. So I was really grateful for that insight from one who would know. Anyway, I didn't even remember saying that to her, but I'm so glad that it helped her. But she crushed it. She crushed it. She crushed it. She was great. Well, listen, let's go back to this board meeting. They've been waiting for Ned. They decide, forget it. We're just going to go on without him.
我当时就问，哪一次？她说，那是2024年派对的前一天晚上。她说，我那天正准备去拍《报社》，你给了我一些很棒的建议。你说过，“别去刻意当个搞笑的人。如果你觉得还能把表演收得更紧凑一点，那就去做吧。”哦，你有点把肯·夸皮斯（Ken Kwapis）给你的导演指导传授给她了。完全正确。她说，所以我只是照着把故事讲出来，我太庆幸自己这么做了。她说，我觉得这让我看起来更好笑。而且她说，这是一个非常大的片场。在我紧张的演员大脑里，我完全有可能用力过猛、表演过度。所以我非常感激过来人的这种见解。不管怎样，我甚至都不记得自己对她说过这话了，但我很高兴这能帮到她。不过她演得太棒了。她演砸了吗？不，她演得太棒了。她太棒了。好吧，听着，让我们回到这个董事会会议。他们一直在等内德。他们决定，算了。我们不等他了，直接开始吧。
What's on the docket today? Well, what's on the docket is that they need money. They're over budget. And Esmeralda says, listen, getting these original stories is expensive. I think we need to go back to the way it was before Ned. Yeah, basically, she's like Ned's idea to do original stories was a bad idea. She's again trying to throw them under the bus. She says they should pay for the wire stories.
今天的议程是什么？嗯，议程是他们需要资金。他们超预算了。埃斯梅拉达说，听着，制作这些原创报道成本很高。我觉得我们得回到内德来之前的状态。对，基本上，她的意思是内德做原创报道的想法是个坏主意。她再次试图把他们推出去当替罪羊。她说他们应该花钱买通讯社的稿件。
But then Oscar brings up a line item. that he found in the budget. That's a little curious. It's a storage unit that they've been renting for nine years. That's actually an apartment. Yeah. So in the peacock version, you guys, it's extended. And you sort of see Oscar really struggling because he knows,
但接着奥斯卡提出了一项支出明细。他在预算里发现了这个。有点奇怪。这是一个他们已经租了九年的储藏单元。那其实是一间公寓。对。所以在孔雀（Peacock）版本里，各位，这段剧情是延伸的。你能看出奥斯卡真的很挣扎，因为他知道，
as Meryl and Ken are trying to sabotage Ned. Yeah. And you can also tell that Oscar maybe believes in Ned and thinks he should stick around and not get fired. Yeah. So he decides to play. this card to save the day, to save Ned. We find out that this storage unit, quote unquote, that's actually an apartment, is Ken's
当玛丽和肯试图破坏内德的计划时。对。而且你也能看出奥斯卡可能很信任内德，觉得他应该留下来而不该被解雇。对。所以他决定打出。这张牌来扭转乾坤，拯救内德。我们发现这个所谓的“储藏单元”，其实是一间公寓，它其实是肯的
apartment. He has a talking head where he says, yeah, Enervate rented him a small furnished apartment for a few weeks when he first moved over from the UK. And somehow it got filed as a warehouse. Ah, could you imagine? Mm-hmm. So he's been sneaky sneak, living rent-free, and billing it. back to the company as a storage facility.
公寓。他有一个独白镜头，里面说，是的，内内特（Enervate）在他刚从英国搬过来时，给他租了一间带家具的小公寓几个星期。不知怎么的，它就被当作仓库归档了。啊，你能想象吗？嗯哼。所以他一直偷偷摸摸地，白住着公寓，却把账单。寄回公司报销为仓储设施。
So back in the meeting, Ken's like, you know what? Let's get rid of this storage unit. No need to investigate what happened. That's a waste of money. But look at that. We'll have the money back in the budget and journalism wins. And then we have just some wrap-up moments, you know. So basically, Esmeralda knows that she's been beat once again.
所以回到会议上，肯就说，你知道吗？咱们把这个储藏单元取消吧。没必要去调查到底发生了什么。那是浪费钱。但你看。这样预算里就有多出来的钱了，新闻业获胜。然后我们还有一些收尾的时刻，你知道的。所以基本上，埃斯梅拉达知道自己又一次被打败了。
And then we have this little moment with Nicole in Detrick. You know, he approaches her desk. And he says, I figured out. the lie, it's that you dated a married guy. And she kind of goes, yeah, nailed it. And she just smiles to herself as he walks away because we realize that he's just there to protect her and help her save face. And she doesn't need to be embarrassed around him. Yeah. I mean, it was a very sweet gesture. Yeah. I think he sort of could see that she was bummed. She was kind of shutting down. Mm-hmm. And so he went over and like gave her an out.
然后我们迎来了妮可和迪特里克的这个小片刻。你知道的，他走近她的办公桌。然后他说，我想通了。那个谎言，就是你和一个已婚男约会过。她有点笑着说，没错，猜中了。当他走开时，她自己微微一笑，因为我们意识到他去那里只是为了保护她，帮她保住面子。她不需要在他面前感到尴尬。对。我的意思是，这是一个非常甜蜜的举动。对。我觉得他某种程度上看出她很难过。她有点情绪低落。嗯哼。所以他走过去给了她一个台阶下。
Yeah, exactly. And then we have this mayor talking head where she's made the decision to stay, you know, she's not going to take the job at the hotel. She says, I'm young, and the hospitality world will always be there. Yeah. And then she says, bye to Ned. She says, all right, I'll see you tomorrow. And he's like, you will? He's like so happy. Yes. And they do this very awkward fist bump. And he's like, all right, buddy. And she's like, yeah, right, dude. And that's where we get the name of this episode, Buddy. And the dude. Yeah. And that's the end of this paper episode. It's very sweet. Mar and Ned finished their first article, and it's a big win. Mm-hmm. I was very excited for them.
对，完全是这样。然后我们有了市长的独白镜头，她已经做好了留下的决定，你知道的，她不会去酒店接受那份工作。她说，我还年轻，酒店业永远都在那里。对。然后她向内德告别。她说，好吧，明天见。而他却说，真的吗？他看起来高兴极了。是的。他们来了一个非常尴尬的碰拳。然后他说，好吧，老兄。她则说，对啊，没错，伙计。这就是本集名字“伙计”与“老兄”的由来。对。这就是《报社》这一集的结尾。非常温馨。马尔和内德完成了他们的第一篇文章，这是一次巨大的胜利。嗯哼。我为他们感到非常兴奋。
Yeah. And we're starting to see a little budding romance, maybe, or friendship, at least, between Detrick and Nicole. And we're starting to see that Oscar might be invested in this idea of a successful paper. And there you have it. There you have it. Big thank yous to Greg Daniels, Creed Bratton, Chelsea Frye, and Patrick Kang. Thank you guys so much for talking to us about this episode.
对。而且我们开始看到迪特里克和妮可之间萌生出了一点浪漫情愫，或者至少是友情。我们开始看到奥斯卡可能也投入到了这个打造成功报社的构想中。事情就是这样。事情就是这样。非常感谢格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）、克里·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）、切尔西·弗莱（Chelsea Frye）和帕特里克·康（Patrick Kang）。非常感谢你们跟我们聊这一集。
We're really enjoying this. I can't wait for next week. Yes, and thank you to everyone that's gone to the website and to our little folders and written comments or questions. Keep them coming. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate
我们真的很享受这个过程。我已经迫不及待想看下周了。是的，也非常感谢所有访问网站、浏览我们的小文件夹并留下评论或问题的人。请继续留言吧。我们下周见。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Wondery/Audacy）的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。执行制作人为卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的助理
producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
制作人是艾斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubbicoe）。奥德赛的执行制作人为莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿演奏的《Ruppertree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。